This right over here is an exercise about the
Spanish-American war and AP American history
on Khan Academy and we start off in student mode
and notice if the student asks for an explanation
it doesn't just give the answer it does what a
good tutor would do and just try to nudge the
student in the right direction and also notice
that everything is monitored the teacher can see
what the student is interacting with as a safety
measure now if we turn student mode off and we
go into teacher mode we see it's very different
when the teacher asks for an explanation it's like
having the teacher's guide it will give as you can
see a very detailed explanation and if the teacher
wants a lesson plan for it well they just need
to ask for it and they will get a very detailed
lesson plan with objectives and activities and
things to do for homework and then if the teacher
says all right that's great Khanmigo you said
give a handout or give a reflection for homework
actually give the reflection assignment and once
again it will construct that for the teacher and
if a teacher likes they can ask to customize
these lesson plans or these prompts or these
Reflections as much as they like to make it more
relevant to what their students are doing this
is something that teachers oftentimes spend
hours a day working on and we hope to save
them a lot of time and a lot of energy for
their own well-being and for their students